maybe this is a small tangent but
let me ask you um on the topic of
academia
you're kind of uh we talked about jordan
peterson
there's a lot of sort of renegade type
of thinkers
certainly in psychology but it applies
in all disciplines
what are your thoughts about academia
being
a place to uh
harbor people like yourself that you
know
people who think deeply about things
who are not constrained by sort of the
who i don't i don't think you're quite
controversial
no not really but you are
a person who thinks deeply about things
and it feels like
um academia can sometimes stifle that
i think so so my concern right now lex
for
young scholars is that
the restrictions and
expectations are such that it's highly
unlikely that anybody will do anything
of great value or
innovation except
for and this is not a bad thing but
stepwise improvement
of existing paradigms so
the you know in simple english you know
i went to princeton for a job interview
40 years ago and they're like what are
you gonna do
if we give you a job and i'm like i
don't know i want to
think about it and read and um
and i i saw that that interview was over
the window of opportunity shut
in my face and they actually called my
mentors
and they're like what are you doing tell
this guy to buy some pants
i had hair down to my waist also he's
like this guy looks like charles manson
and jesus but
the expectation is that you come to a
post
you know you start publishing so that
you can get grants that's certainly true
but there's also kind of a behavioral
thing you said like long hair
there's uh there's a certain style of
the way you're supposed to behave for
example
like i'm wearing a suit it sounds con
it sounds weird but i feel comfortable
in this i would you know i wore it like
when i was teaching at mit
i wore it sure uh warranty meetings and
so on the different uh
sometimes a blue and red tie but
like that was an outsider thing to do at
mit
so like there was a strong pressure to
not wear a suit
no that's right it's and there's a
pressure to behave to have a hair
thing no that's right the way you wear
your hair the way you
uh this isn't like a liberal or a level
he's just the pr in tribes that's right
and academia to me or a place
any place that dreams of having like
renegade free thinkers like really deep
thinkers
should in fact like glorify
the outsider right yeah should welcome
just
should welcome uh you know uh people
that don't fit in
yeah no that sounds weird but i don't i
could just imagine an interview
with at princeton you know like i
imagine why aren't people
why aren't you at uh harvard for example
or mit
um yeah well so that look i would love
to
uh you know i
i haven't lectured at mit but i've
lectured at harvard i
i've gotten to lecture at almost every
place
that wouldn't consider me for a job yeah
and i um
well a few things i'm lucky because i
you know i go to princeton i'm like i
don't know what i want to do
then two days later i go to skidmore and
i'm like i don't know what i want to do
and they offer me a job later that day
which i declined for months because of
the extraordinary pressure
of my mentors who right-mindedly felt
that
i wouldn't get much done there and
but what they told me at skidmore was
take your time
you know show up for your classes and
don't molest barnyard animals
and you'll probably get tenure and i'm
like i'll show up for my classes we'll
talk
it was that was the negotiation yeah i
negotiated i drove a hard bargain
but but honestly lex that's
i feel i'm very committed to skidmore
because
i was given tenure when our first terror
management paper
wasn't published it took eight years to
publish it was rejected at every journal
and i submitted it as like a purple
ditto sheet thing
i'm like here's what i've been doing
here's the reviews
here's why i think this is still a
pretty good idea
and i don't know that this would happen
even at skimmer anymore
but i i was very lucky to be given the
latitude and to be encouraged
i i took classes at skidmore that's how
i learned all this stuff i
i graduated i got a phd unscathed by
knowledge
we were great statisticians and
methodologists
but we didn't have any substance
you know i and i don't mean this
cynically but we were trained in a
method in search of a question
so i appreciate having five years at
skidmore basically
to read books and i also appreciate that
i look like this 40 years ago
and my view
is that
this is how i comported myself
other people my the guy i learned the
most from
at skidmore's now dad a history
professor ted carota
he wore a bow tie and there's another
guy darnell rucker who taught me about
philosophy
and he was very proper
and he had like his jacket with like the
leather patches but these guys weren't
pompous at all they were this is
the way i am and i always felt that
that's
important that somebody who looks at you
and says oh what a stiff he's probably
an mba
yeah well they're wrong yeah and someone
who looks at me
when i first got to skidmore other
professors would ask
when i'd be coming to their office to
empty the garbage they just assumed you
know i was in my 20s they assumed i was
housekeeping
i always felt that was important that
the students learn not to judge an idea
by the appearance of the person who
purveys it
and yeah i mean that's uh i i guess this
is such a
high concern now because i
personally still have faith that
academia is where the great geniuses
will come from i do too
and great ideas i love hearing you say
that i i still
and it's one of the reasons why um
really apprehensive about the future of
education right now
in the context of the pandemic i um
oh yeah is that a lot of folks
i need a lot of these are google type
people who i don't you know they're
geniuses
also but i don't like this idea that all
learning can be virtual and that much
could happen
i'm big on embodied environments with
actual humans
yeah interacting i mean there's there's
so much
to the university education but i think
the key part
that i uh is the the mentorship that
occurs
somehow and at the human level like i've
gotten a lot of flack
like this conversation we're in in
person now
and i've uh
even with edward snow snowden who done
all interviews remote i'm a stickler
to in person it has to be in person like
and a lot of people just don't get it
they're like well why can't this is so
much easier
like why go through the pain like i've
traveled
i'm traveling in the next month to paris
for a single stupid conversation nobody
cares about
just to be in person well it's important
to me i
i honestly i was like
this and thank you for coming down today
well it's my pleasure but
again this is very self-serving i've
enjoyed this i knew i was going to
but it's not about our enjoyment per se
um again at the risk is sounding
cavalier
there are a host of factors
beyond verbal yeah that i don't believe
can be adequately captured i don't care
how much the acuity is decent on a zoom
conversation i
i feel uh again i
i felt within five minutes
that this was gonna be for me
easy in the sense that i could speak
freely i just
don't see that happening so easily from
a distance
yeah i i tend to well i'm hopeful uh
i agree with you on the current
technology but i am hopeful unlike
some others on the technology eventually
being able to create that kind of
experience oh i think
we're quite far away from that but yeah
it might be able my hope is
i'm you know i'm i'm hopeful i was at
microsoft in seattle and i can't
remember why
and no i i can't i i i
that's how i'm in my early mr magoo
phase and and somebody there was
showing us like a virtual wall
where the entire wall you know
when you're talking to somebody so it's
life-size
and they were beginning the
get the appearance of motion and stuff
it looked pretty
yeah with virtual reality too i don't
know if you've ever been inside a
virtual world
yeah it's to me it's uh i can just
i can see the future it's uh it's it's
quite real yeah in terms of like a
terror of death
uh i'm afraid of heights me too
and there's i don't know if you've ever
tried uh you should if you haven't
there's a virtual reality experience
where you can walk a plank
yeah you can look down and uh man i was
on the ground like
i was like i was afraid i was deeply
afraid i was
is it was it was as real as uh
yep as anything else could be in i mean
these are very early days of that
technology
relatively speaking so um
yeah i mean i don't know what to do with
that same with like crossing the street
we did these experiments
across the street in front of a car and
uh
you know it's being run over by a car
uh it's terrifying yeah it's just that
yeah so there is a rich experience to be
created there
we're not there yet but uh
yeah and i've seen a lot of people try
like you said the google folks
silicon valley folks try to create a
virtual online education
i don't know i think they've raised
really important questions
absolutely like what makes uh
the education experience fulfilling what
makes it
effective yeah these are important
questions and i think what they
highlight is we have no clue
you